can you choose anything about the next
Avengers are you in
am i in we have a start date I have yet
to be released from my Marvel contract
you heard it here first constitute uh as
a big date night out for you guys
a rare David we said actually we were
getting kind of dolled up to come out
and I was like my god we're actually
going out together tonight kicking off
the holiday season I mean honor tonight
a shining star award that responsibility
of being a a real-life superhero feel a
the opportunity that playing Ironman has
given me and what it means to a lot of
these kids are fighting for their lives
it's such a big deal for the families
and not really you know that really
pulls in our heartstrings and being
parents and also I feel like we get a
lot of inspiration from the families and
oh my god I just I see what these kids
and parents go through and I just the
strength they have is so encouraging and
as I said to Robert is great it as it is
for the kids I see what it does for the
families for the parents and it just
it's kind of doubly you know good stuff
a lot of kids speaking of are very
excited about spider-man homecoming
what's it like working with Tom Holland
and why is he the perfect spider-man
it's a 21st century take on it I think
it's I'm really excited at the way it's
being kind of reimagined good friends
with Toby so you know I can't play
favorites here but that's how Colin guy
is is something else and she can always
tell I was in a good mood you know when
I was shooting my little bit in it so
that means it must be an excellent an
excellent motion picture
you